the Internet's of the first ones for you
Ray do you believe that these benefits
of singularity would be shared by
humanity as a whole rather than being
reserved for the elite a little good
question well I mean take mobile phones
only the wealthy could afford them 20
years ago when they didn't work very
well and they did one thing poorly now
that they do a million things and work
pretty well there are 5 billion of them
in the world and they're pretty
inexpensive so technology become I've
billion cell phones yeah so almost
everybody has one everyone will have a
smartphone virtually within a few years
and so by the time the technology
actually works well it's very
inexpensive that's because there's a 50
percent deflation rate when it comes to
information technology one of my
computation memory communication comes
down by 50 percent every year and yet
with healthcare for example I mean
America this rich nation that's
supposedly leading the world even though
we're 37th I think in health care the UN
rates is we certainly can't even make
all our people's people well health care
because it's read medicine it's not it
factoring in greed dark medicine is
still hit or miss the new paradigm is to
actually reprogram our biology you and I
have outdated software running in our
bodies I'd like to tell but my people
can't get a tooth pulled
I mean I'd like to tell my fat insulin
receptor gene you don't need to hold on
to every calorie I'm compromising the
next hunting season that the supermarket
will be good all right that's where
we're heading up old software I heard
you say that in your movie like software
fine thousands of years ago there's not
a metaphor it's a real thing and that's
the new paradigm to really change the
information processes underlying biology
that's going to progress exponentially
health of Medicine has we've made
progress as I said before longevity was
37 in 1800 but it's been progressing
linearly because it's been hit-or-miss
how old are you back to be people think
I look pretty good for 95
but I'm actually 63 but I do come out
younger on yeah
biological aging Tennessee because you
take all those pills exactly what are
the pills another use I heard you say in
the movie that some of these pills can
actually reverse the aging process well
I'll give a jegging there's a dozen
different processes I'll give you an
example of a simple one there's a
substance phosphatidylcholine
complicated name that gets depleted from
the cell membrane that's why the skin is
soft and supple and a baby that is why
the skin is rigid and not flexible and
an elderly person the organs don't work
very well you can reverse that it's
really great at 29 it's pretty good at
29 but it's not grated 89 usually but
you can reverse that by supplementing
with that substance so that's one
example then if you have problems with
sugar or cholesterol or homocysteine
there are things you can do to address
those so I actually was diagnosed 30
years ago with type 2 diabetes but with
this program I have no I've had no
indication of diabetes for 25 years yeah
I mean and everybody could do that yeah
yeah you know everybody can do that if
they have the right ideas and they're
diligent you don't eat meat do you Kevin
no I don't I just wanted to prove that
he could not make a joke all right does
anyone on the panel believe that the
economy would be in any better shape if
we had a different president well
there's a softball write down the plate
for the right side of our panel well
here's I mean actually here's one one
reason that maybe doesn't reflect well
on Republicans in a sense but when you
do sort of like psychological
experiments and so on and look at sort
of how partisans on both sides react to
presidents of the other party people
tend to overstate the bad things and
understate the good things right during
a so when Clinton was president
Republicans were more likely to say the
deficit had gone up even though it went
gone down and then when Reagan was
president Democrats were more likely to
say the economy was bad even when it's
good now most businessmen in this
generalization are Republicans so you
could make an argument that businessmen
right now be
cuz a Democrat is president are
understating you know are more
pessimistic than they should be just
because of that partisan biased so
really we need to elect a Republican in
2012 in order to trick those businessmen
into investing in the American economy
did you follow that house it I actually
did yeah I know and you know what that's
true
and that's the case for Mitt Romney
Obama but Obama sort of in the same
situation because whatever he does the
Republicans do the opposite it's like
whatever he touches has cooties politics
I've never seen it quite like this I
know I mean he was last time your crowd
talking about the War Powers Act I never
heard you talk about in my life right
what suddenly discovered that Libya's
humanitarian thing they don't like so
they're invoking the War Powers Act
Boehner is even saying I don't really
believe in it but it's my job to do it
now I heard a politician say they never
met a country they didn't want to
bombers
like the American public is tired of
this they've had a lot of anxiety we
fought on so many wars I mean the
president has done hasn't talked about
Libya in a month to the public it's
about time that he wastes now in Somalia
and and Panama and a Grenada and live at
Lebanon they just pile one actually
Reagan's Reagan to pulled us out of love
love wars but remember Newt Gingrich he
was like Obama needs to bomb Libya
yesterday as soon as Obama started
bombing lippies like what the [ __ ] is
this black guy doing what are we doing
he was he turned on a dime
Boehner wanted to abolish the War Powers
Act back in the nineties right well
right but it's the same thing yeah the
other way I mean if you look at what I
mean again these games but if you look
at what Obama said about the war spec
War Powers Act when when Bush was
president he was saying well you know
clearly the president they were talking
about bombing Iran and he said well
clearly the president is a little
different at the debt ceiling Obama
bombing Iran is actually a serious four
I mean Iran Iran says we can't wait to
get in and do it the two parties
recently has been pretty rough on your
side on wars and we got into Iraq which
is an idiot well I mean I feel like you
and I are similar that we used to be a
lot more down the middle and the
Republican Party moved so far to the
right but now we look like the scariest
thing a guy have limited mental power
george w bush talked this country this
wasn't out of it this was a Winston
Churchill this was a guy about a little
bit below average edibility and he
taught this country into war or the
country that never attacked it somehow
Iraq attacked us on 9/11 just within
memory of many leading Democrats voting
yeah
your son you're right it's an
embarrassment they cost a lot in their
careers I'd say it's horrible that were
right and and we kind of call out those
Democrats yeah you should call out the
Democrats
okay I'm well I'm just saying I don't
always close round I'm just saying just
say just because they're on the blue
team they're right listen if you look
bill if you look at the history of
American war making going back through
Vietnam degree and all the rest there's
no partisan pattern the party in power
is more likely to start wars because
they're in power and the party out of
power is more likely to say and that's
do you think anybody by George W with
his limited ability surrounded by the
neocons would it take us in that war
yeah Chris I agree that Reagan probably
wouldn't have taken us into that war but
there were a lot of there no I think the
Iraq like you people
[Applause]
Thank You panel
[Applause]